so what happens in 2022 you think uh by
november
it's going to be just
like you think the polls are wrong and
it's going to be a crazy blowout we've
never seen before a republican super
majority or something yeah i think
you'll see uh probably gaining 30 35
seats we're not at about 212 213 we'll
probably gain 30 to 35 seats and that
that's that's a big number i think i
think it actually could end up being
better than uh republicans realize it
could because if the polls have been
consistently
uh skewed in favor of democrats and
right now in the generic ballot
republicans are up about three points
they're probably at 10.
then you look at uh interestingly five
i'm sorry real clear politics has the uh
the toss-up seats and i think 28 of 32
toss-ups are democrat held
so it's just like it might be way bigger
than people realize
i wouldn't be surprised if it was less
than we realized as well i don't know
there's still a few months to go here so
yeah let's just wait and see what
happens but let's let's talk beyond that
though what do you think you think joe
biden's going to run again well i hope
he does i i should she
i really do and i'd send him 25
if anybody knows his mailing address
i'll send them 25 bucks uh she's worse
than he but i think the democrats in
trouble because i don't think they
really have a candidate right now um and
and so they got nobody that's that's why
they're so desperate to try and bring
trump back to life yeah and and i i
think right now our country um when you
look at when trump was president for the
four years i mean we didn't have all
these crisis i mean just name one or two
i mean covert was difficult yet but i
thought he handled that quite well with
the vaccine in record time but i i think
we need him back in 2024 i think this
guy donald trump uh in my humble opinion
loves this country more than just about
anything but what about what about
desantis do you think you think trump
would be better i think i think desantis
should keep his powder dry till 2028. i
mean he's relatively young manny what
mid-40s or so and he's been you know
he's a member of congress i think he's
been governor now for what four years
and and i just think in 2028 he'd be
great and and there's competition going
back and forth with our governor in
texas as well who's going to who's going
to get that base who's going to move her
further right but i just think everybody
should just
bow out and just let donald trump come
back he will be the republican nominee
and he will beat anybody what is it i
want to hear two words from donald trump
the moment he gets he gets inaugurated
you're fired
beautiful words
i want him to just fire all of these
bureaucratic administrative state trash
people in dc we have a lot of talent i
mean when you think of ron desantis and
the great things he's doing in florida
people love him so i think we have a lot
of good talent out there and and we have
people for in the wings in the future
the democrats are just struggling who
corey booker i mean who do you got the
democrats are just struggling they don't
have anything
bernie crazy bernie give me a break i do
like bernie better than newsome to be
fair uh bernie if there was any democrat
i'd i'd rather have bernie but i think
bernie's a sellout so i think they're
all good
what is it specifically about trump
that
energizes you so much is it that he was
an outsider or is it
was it him before he ran for president
or the way he governed for four years
the way he ran the way he ran he had 14
people on that stage and he just picked
him off one at a time he's just real
he's i thought he brought a lot of humor
he was kind of funny i mean yeah
nicknames and people don't like the way
he calls names but overall and and
when he come up would build that wall
build that wall that really energized
his campaign and and so i just think
that you can't buy him
you can't buy donald trump he has all
the money there's no special interest
going to get him and just the way he ran
the country uh he deserves a uh a third
term are you familiar with the uh tales
from an economic hitman that book oh
yeah so you've heard of this yeah if
luke were here he'd be able to educate
us properly but the general idea is this
guy said that you know he worked for the
intelligence agents in the uh agencies
in the u.s and what they would do is
they would go and try and bribe you know
uh
a country and say like here's what the
united states wants we'll give you all
this stuff if you're doing the imf will
come with loans and then if the
president or the government said no then
they would try and take out either
politically or through assassinations
and if that didn't work invasion that's
what he claimed i i think about those
stories and i'm like whether or not
they're true or not you look at donald
trump
he gets elected they didn't think he
would he has these meetings they
probably were like you know trump play
ball with us here's what we're gonna do
and he went no we're doing it my way i
don't want to do it and then they try to
remove him via uh you know a legal
process russia gate
that doesn't work so what do they do now
executive action now they're going with
the january 6th the law enforcement
stuff the accusations the doj the fbi
raids so they've escalated the point
where they're like we are going to use
the force of violence against this man
to stop him from running i had to reread
that book now
yeah it's crazy he's talking about like
panama stuff and it wasn't like a a
small conspiracy book it was a new york
times bestseller it was you know right
right right now listen i got a lot of
people they don't like his tweets they
don't like what he said they don't like
maybe some of the stuff he said about
john mccain and when he was a prisoner
of war and all whatever right and i
tried to and
just there's some other things but i've
always said i said you guys
you're not electing your neighbor and
we're not electing the pope
right we're electing the president
united states and when you look at his
policies and the results of those
policies
ukraine would be the prime example obama
went into what 2014 went into crimea
right nobody went into ukraine under
donald trump did he putin didn't go into
ukraine and donald trump now you get and
so you have you have our adversaries
that are taken and exploiting our
weakness and we have weakness in our
president today donald trump ran this i
mean just look at how he kept
russia in check and how he kept china in
check i mean
look at this
no invasion from russia while trump was
president despite crimea then all of a
sudden trump gets in and putin backs off
i understand so i just think listen i'm
a trump guy i i hope he comes back uh he
doesn't drink doesn't smoke i think he's
uh he's very healthy right now i've had
opportunities to visit with him a couple
times and and i think uh this country
needs him more today than ever man you
know it would help you should tell him
to come on the podcast well i i think i
think we're actually setting that up
there you go no for real here we go yeah
we're we'll have to go he'd like you
guys oh yeah oh yeah we're fans we're
yeah we're good thing about it is he
wouldn't have to dress up well i don't
know
i'm not wearing i used to but it wasn't
appreciated sheamus i'm just kidding
buddy
uh but by the way if he'll if he agrees
to be in the vlog i'm a fan yeah yeah he
gets money that would be great
get trump to do like a simple bit i mean
he was in home alone you know
yeah that'd be cool if he was in new
york um
so i i i don't uh
you know a lot of a lot of people who
are trump zealots you know they're just
like trump's the best you can do it
wrong i'm like trump's pretty good he's
all right i didn't vote for him in 2016
in 2022 i did i said you can't deny the
successes he's had getting rid of the
trans-pacific partnership was the right
move every activist in the world okay
every actors in the united states were
complaining about tpp
then trump comes in and all of a sudden
they were like actually it's a good
thing and i'm like
what like during occupy wall street like
all throughout everyone's like warning
about this trans-pacific partnership
trump gets in and gets rid of it donald
trump no new wars
starts bringing our troops back from the
middle east these are good things i was
talking to someone and they told me oh
it was all it was all nonsense he tried
to be buddy buddy with dictators and
blah blah and i was like what does that
mean and they're like like him and kim
jong-un and then i said
donald trump crossed the dmz into north
korea with no security detail and
they're
yeah and i'm like that is one of the
most profound acts of leadership
someone could take to try and end a war
they could have captured the president
of the united states
and they could have done whatever they
wanted and trump walked in with kim
jong-un and walked back and i was just i
was shocked if dennis rodman can do it
i'm going to do it but i mean in all
seriousness i mean you're the president
united states walking into what should
be perceived as hospital territory i'm
like this is amazing that's amazing i i
got to vote for this guy and then what
happened was his second term agenda came
out and i was like school choice get rid
of these uh cult these these critical
race theory garbage stuff and i'm just
like
this dude's done well i just deserves it
i talk about this all the time i scream
about it on my podcast and twitter and
all that stuff people need
principals not teams right if you were
mad when george bush had drone strikes
that killed civilians you should be mad
when obama did it if you were mad trump
did it yeah if you thought um
you know bill uh trump was creepy with
women you should think that bill clinton
was creepy with women right joe biden
yeah it's with children yeah i mean
there are so many instances where and
that doesn't mean suddenly you have to
disavow them that doesn't mean you have
to go from democrat to republican
republican to democrat it just means
have the political courage to stand in
your conviction and call out your side
when your side is wrong in order to make
your side better and hold it accountable
and then we can actually have a more
honest political discourse one million
percent and i i really just want to hit
on this point i i made sort of a little
joke alluding to but the president of
the united states sniffs children
and we're used to it like we don't think
of it as being that out of the ordinary
it's just you know it's almost because
you know punchline but the president
sniffs
children he gropes them too it's
disgusting you see the picture wasn't
there anywhere like you pinched a little
girl's nipple or something what
it appears that most people too they
look him at like a grandfather figure
and they almost kind of feel for him
like this is grandpa joe yeah remember
when he created and it's almost like the
excuses it's so weird yeah
i just i just think about
our country our country is begging for
leadership yeah and i think we had that
with trump i we don't have that with
this current administration uh he's let
around by his knowledge and and we're
paying the price we're paying the price
i think in a lot of ways desantis is
better but i don't know if desantis
would come in and do the you're fired
thing that that's that's the big issue
right yeah so with with ron desantis
he's proven his leadership in florida
he's done a really great job and i think
he'd be a fantastic president i'm not so
sure on foreign policy that's it to be
seen
but
i'd imagine if he did get in if he were
to win in 2024 if he ran and won
he would not go you're fired and he
would not get rid of all these really
awful people i think trump
he knows he's learned his lesson and he
was like i trusted some bad people if he
if he gets in in 2024 it is going to be
beautiful as the pink slips start
getting handed out and then you see
people walking out of the
the buildings in dc and going into the
the unemployment line i think trump's
going to do i don't think desantis would
do it who would have ever thought
our country could be destroyed in 17
months huh 17 18 months he's destroyed
this country so it's going to take a
full four years of donald trump to come
back and try to fix these issues and and
oil and gas is so important in texas and
you know now you have five dollar fuel
inflation eight and a half percent so i
i love uh oh sorry i i was gonna say i i
just love the the
the meme where um the left says
joe biden doesn't control gas prices
idiot but joe biden's going to enact
policies to lower gas prices right yeah
it's like what do you what so can you
did he enact policies to make them
higher no
but he can make them lower okay dude
whatever well and so i i try to keep
a sort of a larger perspective and so
you know under the obama administration
i remember thinking like i really really
don't like obama but you know we had fdr
we had woodrow wilson maybe obama isn't
the worst president we've had joe biden
may actually be the worst president in
all of american history i mean at least
the really really bad ones like wilson
and fdr knew what day of the week it was
jimmy carter will appreciate that yeah
yeah jimmy carter i mean even carter i
would say i would say uh biden's worse
than carter grant i don't know as much
about jimmy carter thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you